In
its early days, “meme”, which incidentally
is often mispronounced as “me-me” or “meh-meh”,
but in fact should be pronounced “meem”,
primarily was only known and used by certain
academics, but today this neologism is beginning
to reach widespread use thanks to describing
the viral spread of jokes, ideas, etc. via
the internet.
“Meme” was coined by the often controversial
evolutionary biologist Richard Dawkins in
his 1976 book, The Selfish Gene.
In it, he states the following:
We need a name for the new replicator, a noun
that conveys the idea of a unit of cultural
transmission, or a unit of imitation.
‘Mimeme’ comes from a suitable Greek root,
but I want a monosyllable that sounds a bit
like ‘gene’.
I hope my classicist friends will forgive
me if I abbreviate mimeme to meme.
If it is any consolation, it could alternatively
be thought of as being related to ‘memory’,
or to the French word même.
It should be pronounced to rhyme with ‘cream’.
The French word même that he references means
“same” or “alike” (though the meaning
changes somewhat depending on how it is used).
The Greek word “mimeme” he derives “meme”
from comes from the Ancient Greek μίμημα
(mīmēma), meaning “that which is imitated”
/ “something imitated” / “something
copied”.
As stated, Dawkins was hoping that the word
would be used as a unit of human cultural
transmission, such as a melody, fashion, or
catch-phrase, with the idea evolving as it
spreads and time passes.
This evolution is primarily spurred by the
fact that people refine the memes or simply
don’t “copy” the information exactly
when they transmit it to another human.
This has since given rise to other derivative
words or phrases including:
Memetics: which explores the transmission
and evolution of cultural ideas in a scientific
manner, though often somewhat unsuccessfully
with the “scientific” part.
Meme Complex or memeplex: memes that have
evolved into a symbiotic relationship with
other memes.
In terms of internet memes, this would be
like the relationship between a meme such
as “Herp/Derp” and various other meme
elements that make up rage comics.
In “real life” memes, this would be like
the combined ideas that together form a certain
religion.
Memotype: the information-content of the meme.
Memeoid: people who are so ingrained with
some meme that they are willing to sacrifice
themselves as a result of it, such as suicide
bombers and the like.
In a less extreme sense, it could be argued
that every single person on the planet is
a memeoid of one type or another.
Memetic Marketing: the use of memes to virally
market some product or business, often using
internet memes.
German biologist Richard Semon in 1904 suggested
a word to mean not only similar to Dawkins’
idea of a meme, but the actual spelling of
the word itself was nearly the same.
In his case, he called it
a Mneme.